this is Startalk all right so let's go
to Jana who is at goddess memoirs on
Twitter mmm sounds good yeah it does
goddess memoirs all right would soil on
Mars force us to genetically modify
foods to be able to grow there because
of less Sun in other words leafless
can't wage Aneta PHY genetic identify ah
feel Jeannette defies all right that we
D can we didn't Etta v plans to the
point where they don't even need
photosynthesis but they can still be
eaten while we eat mushrooms oh wow dude
too too too soon man look at that
Touche so all that aside I do eat
mushrooms as a matter of fact I'm still
having flashbacks from the last oh man I
can't hear you so everybody I know it
sounds so romantic to go live on Mars to
some of us among which I am NOT whom a
usage intended for comedic effect
everybody Mars is cold crazy cold and
the Sun is less than a quarter as bright
so it's dim I mean I know we take
pictures there but these are with
cameras that are where the iris or the
the system is set up to capture a lot of
light before the picture is sent home
here to earth so not only live if you
have season can't agree more
yes and you can't breathe gotcha so
everybody it sounds so romantic
if you really want to colonize Mars go
to Antarctica for a couple years okay
and don't no not on the shore where the
birds are gendered orcas grabbing the
Penguins out of midair no no none of us
happy feet so right yes none of that you
go where it hasn't snowed in over a
century and see what the Dry Valleys and
see what you think try it for a couple
years sorry by the way don't even
breathe take all the scuba tanks you
need just to simulate it so I want to go
to Mall
I want to look for signs of life on Mars
I'm the first guy to do that but I don't
want to go colonize it and then
genetically modified crops so they
modify crops so they can survive in a
greenhouse on Mars that would be
charming right but it's not a big goal
of mine so what would be more I know
we're still in GMOs but I just got to
ask what would be more desirable
colonizing Mars or colonizing the moon
Wow
I'm sorry I didn't mean to elicit that
kind of death vacuum or death by
freezing I mean either one yeah
but the moon would be fierce the thing
in Antarctica we have a science base we
have McMurdo Station that people go
there and they do scientific research
they make amazing discoveries about the
hole in the ozone about climate change
about the ice sheet sliding off the
continent of Antarctica gotcha very
important earth used to be so warm
ancient dinosaurs wander around in that
continent but back in the day what yes
right but we make those discoveries
that's good but you don't go there to
live you go there to work and you hang
out for a while
it's like la I got you from your permit
respect so for our viewers who are not
in the United States LA is Los Angeles
California and Chuck I think as a native
New Yorker ah is Philadelphian by
Philadelphia and even more troubling as
a national space ball fan he's put s
shoes poo poos is disrespectful of our
beloved Los Angeles love Los Angeles
just couldn't live there so anyway the
same is true of Mars now genetically
modifying plants to make it on Mars a
worthy undertaking but not something I
want to spend a lot of invest a lot of
intellect and treasure on this is
Startalk
you